les failles ici complètement sèche voilà
tout noir ça sauf une foutue années 2016
du gel et de la grêle au printemps des
pluies diluviennes en juin puis la
sécheresse pendant tout l'été des aléas
climatiques exceptionnelles par leur
intensité mais qui sont récurrentes en
ce début de xxième siècle et cela
inquiète les vignerons alors depuis
début 2015 la profession s'est dotée
d'un nouvel organisme censé mieux
répondre aux interrogations liées au
changement climatique aux maladies de la
vigne ou à l'innovation technique et
commercial ce nouvel outil
c'est le vino paul implantée à amboise
en indre et loire
ça correspond bien effectivement soit
aurait souhaité comme met en avant le
coût nous propose c'est diffusé comment
la direction de cet établissement est
bicéphale
à l'image de son rôle de trait d'union
entre la recherche et les producteurs il
y a donc une directrice ingénieurs de
l'institut français de la vigne et du
vin et un président viticulteurs dans
l'appellation cheverny un duo garant de
l'ambition initiale du projet quand on
prend les partenaires séparément ils ont
des qualifications des compétences voilà
est ce qu on a cherché à faire c'est
mettre en synergie toutes ses
compétences pour décupler décupler les
savoir-faire décupler les possibilités
de transfert de connaissances de
recherche
de formation pour une meilleure
efficacité de nos organismes
levine au pôle est donc au coeur d'un
réseau de partenaires unis au service
des vignerons du val de loire ce qui
ressemble ici à un atelier de
dégustation de raisin est justement
l'illustration de son fonctionnement
interactif ce que ça se passe bien et
lisa sion belle résonne chez nous pour
l'instant ça se passait bien là on a
recalé les descripteurs et la façon dont
déguste les viticulteurs régionaux en
réclamer ces tests effectués à amboise
pour améliorer la production du chemin
un cépage historique du val de loire
apparu dès le 4ème siècle et pourtant
encore méconnu sous bien des aspects
l'objectif c'est aussi ça c'est de
caractériel raisin de caractériser le
vin qui va être issus de ces parcelles à
le tout cette chorale est un petit peu
ces chastes et physico chimiques sur la
veille les caractéristiques aromatiques
sur le vin et puis le côté sensorielle
s'estimant la demande en fait des
syndicats n'ont pas la foi donc vous
vraiment louis donc touraine donc sur le
développement puce fictivement sur la
partie typologie des produits lorsqu'on
ne faisait pas forcément de cours au
préalable l'objet c'est de pouvoir ont
fait enrichir les bases de données du
coup existantes de les faire vivre
et donc on va utiliser ce qui a déjà été
acquis ou alors important un plus par
rapport à ce qu'ils ne disposent
aujourd'hui au terme de données
contamine les feuilles le travail de
recherche commence parfois au sein même
du laboratoire du vino pole ici on prend
tout particulièrement en compte les
innovations en matière de protection de
l'environnement ont créé par exemple des
produits de biocontrôle à base
d'extraits naturels de plantes pour
lutter contre l'une des principales
maladies de la vigne
ici au laboratoire on travaillait
surtout sur les problématiques de
mildiou donc on est sur des
les produits naturels qu'on essaye de
développer pour assurer une protection
des eaux contre cette maladie là les
thématiques qui sont le plus travailler
sur des produits d'origine naturelle ou
des mécanismes venant de la nature pour
limiter les mécanismes déjà existants
dans le vignoble pour limiter au maximum
l'utilisation de produits de traitement
alors c'est sûr ses rangs la fois on a
quand même eu un peu de symptômes que ce
soit sur grappes ou sur feuilles pour
tester dans la nature ces produits de
lutte biologique
levine au pôle a la chance d'avoir aussi
comme partenaire son plus proche voisin
il s'agit du lycée viticole d'amboise
dont le domaine libère quelques rangs de
ses vignes pour faire avancer la
recherche
donc non protocole d'expérimentation
dans les prochains oui on va sûrement
tourner les modalités mais normalement
tout tout devrait se passer à peu près
de la même façon les extraits de serment
sont pulvérisés ici de la même façon que
au laboratoire en préventif en général
une fois par semaine tout au long de la
campagne et ont fait des comptages 2010
ou non qu'on vérifie la surface foliaire
à quel moment elle est atteinte
comment la maladie se développe au fur
et à mesure des semaines et de sa se
pourvoir quantifier l'efficacité des
produits conteste c'est vraiment un
exemple très concret je pense de ce qui
peut être mis en place par des molécules
naturelles qu'on peut extraire de la
vigne sert comment protéger la vigne par
ses propres défenses naturelles
il ya tout ce qui est polyphénols et
actis armes c'est un exemple vraiment
concret de ce qu'on pourra faire dans
l'avenir et les résultants plus sûr très
probants très intéressant donc c'est
vraiment parmi toutes les espérances
qu'on peut faire une qui a vraiment les
débouchés je pense lever les plus
rapides
ce qui constitue la grande nouveauté est
peut-être la principale force du réseau
créé par levine au pôle c'est
l'intégration des universités régionales
dans ce vaste partenariat au service de
la viticulture l'université françois
rabelais de tours est désormais
sollicité dans le cadre de plusieurs
projets de recherche concernant la
biodiversité la viticulture durable ou
ici au laboratoire du gecko géo
hydrosystèmes continentaux les problèmes
d'érosion des sols
ce laboratoire en fait est spécialisé
dans les recherches sur les six qu'on
appelle les systèmes fluviaux
donc on essaye de comprendre en fait
commencé système fonctionne du point de
vue principalement physique
donc on s'intéresse surtout nous est ce
qu'on appelle le transfert de matière
dans les dans les bassins on travaille
principalement sur le bassin de la loire
mais on a bien sûr des chantiers aussi
au delà et notamment à l'étranger
pour cette étude sur les sols ce sont
les vignerons de l'appellation chinon
qui ont été demandeurs sur les coteaux
qui surplombe le chinonais certaines
parcelles sont tout bonnement menacée de
disparition
si on observe très bien quand les
conséquences du phénomène d'érosion ou
présents ici dans l'appellation chinon
on voit très bien les racines apparentes
les ceps qui sont des chaussées donc
tout le sol qui est parti du fait de
l'érosion
à l'origine c'est les plantations sont
faites de sorte que la terre arrive à ce
niveau là et on observe qu'après
plusieurs années
l'érosion a fait que le sol est parti et
la physiologie de la vigne on est
bouleversé la nutrition de la vigne se
fait principalement sur les vingt à
trente premiers centimètres
donc on observe clairement ici à un
déficit de sol qui entraîne une
modification de la physiologie de la
vigne et au final de la qualité de la
quantité de récoltes aux laboratoires
universitaires tourangeau des
géosciences et de l'environnement
les chercheurs ont déjà près de deux
années d'observation et de collecte de
données sur l'érosion des sols viticoles
la chine
le constat est clair et les
préconisations concerne d'autres
vignobles comme sancerre ou les coteaux
du vendômois
où certains vignerons vont devoir
changer leurs méthodes de travail sur
les coteaux oui il ya un réel risque
alors le risque est de quelle nature la
première chose c'est encore une fois si
vous avez plus de sol sur une roche dure
bah on ne peut plus faire pousser de vie
mais c'est beaucoup plus compliqué mais
vous avez aussi probablement un impact
sur le fonctionnement de la vigne on l'a
vu par exemple cet été on a eu une
période de sécheresse importante le sol
en fonction de ses propriétés notamment
de son épaisseur va être capable de
contenir plus ou moins d'eau qui va être
restitué à bhl à la vie si jamais vous
diminuez cette capacité vous pouvez
créer potentiellement des problèmes
c'est à dire une disponibilité en eau
insuffisante ou alors dans certains
autres contexte si on se place en bas
des parcelles par exemple là où atterrit
des fois le sol une fois qu'il a été
déplacé au contraire à un excès d'eau ce
qui fait que le fonctionnement de la
vigne va changer et on va généralement
aller vers une qualité moindre du réseau
en conséquence les viticulteurs
expérimente déjà de nouvelles pratiques
notamment ce qui concerne les opérations
de labours ou d'enherbement des grandes
lignes la collaboration universités
monde professionnel vient le vino paul a
donc porté ses fruits levine au pôle
permet de mettre tous les acteurs
ensemble et du coup ça ça demande plus
fort pour arriver à combattre le
problème qu'ils vont nous arriver comme
le changement climatique comme le
problème des ce cas comme d'autres
soucis je pense à des insectes des
choses comme ça qui peuvent arriver et
faire beaucoup de dégâts la viticulture
ça j'espère que ça permette d'aller plus
vite entre la l'identification du
problème la recherche et les résultats
de la recherche un e à la fin quoi à 60
km au nord-est de chinon là où c'est
vous vrai est aussi une terre
d'expérimentation pour le vino paul
centre val de loire
aujourd'hui on connaîtra bien les arômes
du sauvignon qu'on est un peu mieux les
arômes du muscat on connaît très peu les
les molécules aromatiques qui sont
responsables du profil du défunt tous
les acteurs de l'appellation sont réunis
et pascal poupeau que l'on a vu
superviser un atelier de dégustation du
cépage shauna amboise passe son grand
oral devant les viticulteurs un an après
avoir lancé les projets de réseaux et de
conservatoire du chemin
levine au pôle à identifier des pistes
probante pour l'avenir de ce cépage
typique du val de loire
moi je les guide de 3 est comme ça en
prélevant ce matin on voit quand même
l'évolution grâce à un suivi où
l'encours du dizaine de parcelles
représentatives de toute l'appellation
les vignerons pourront un jour établir
de façon quasi scientifique
les dates optimale des vendanges d'une
année sur l'autre
d'une part c'est là une autre puisque
charte passa les différents le
viticulteur pourra avoir des
renseignements sur l'évolution de sa
parcelle en fonction des données météo
puisque c'est surtout ça qui fait qui
fait évoluer le réseau pourra anticiper
un peu mieux qu'il le fait aujourd'hui
et ça peut permettre aussi sur une
parcelle comme cela ou sur d'autres
personnes de d'avoir un petit peu les
limites de la parcelle dans les
conditions qu'on aura modéliser le
viticulteur ça capable de
de vérifier que cette parcelle à il
pourra pas en faire du mois le pas en
faire d'une demi sec
c'était un très beau sec donc ça sert à
rien d'attendre parce qu'on sait que ça
ça évoluera pas vers ce profil c'est un
petit peu c'est l'objectif ces
recherches n'ont pour l'instant le
soutien que d'un noyau de producteurs
mais pour les convaincus elle ouvre une
route vers un véritable eldorado
je pense qu'on est assis sur une mine
d'or en matière de richesse de terroir
de potentiel de terroir et de vin je
pense qu'il faut avancer pour essayer de
mieux maîtriser mieux comprendre et
essayer de booster ce cépage qui est
formidable qu'est le chemin qu'on trouve
un peu partout l'on met finalement son
berceau est sans doute celui ci est
et voilà on a encore beaucoup de choses
à fond levine au pôle d'amboise a donc
du travail pour les prochaines années
mais il voit beaucoup plus loin encore
son grand projet d'avenir pourrait voir
le jour sur ce terrain d'un hectare et
demi placé entre ses propres
laboratoires et du lycée viticole ici
l'ambition est tout bonnement d'inventer
le futur dans tous les domaines de la
viticulture
l'originalité c'est à la fois non de
travailler sur le matériel végétal
également sur tout ce qui a été une
erreur technique en lien bien sûr que
changement climatique et les aspects
effectivement environnementaux donc le
principe c'est que ça soit en fait ce
qu'on appelle une vitrine donc ce sera
en fait la jonction avec le lycée ce qui
est intéressant c'est que ont les moyens
humains et matériels pour nous aider en
fait à la plantation l'entretien la
vigne en dehors du cadre expérimental
qui sera suivi par liev et et ses
partenaires techniques pour ont fait
fictivement mettre en place un prototype
idéal pour répondre en fait aux enjeux
dont des invités culture de demain aux
environs de 30 à 50 ans une vigne du
futur sans équivalent en france mais
dont le financement reste à trouver
quatre cent mille euros sont nécessaires
pour lancer l' aventure l'aboutissement
de ce projet offrirait aux vies nos
pôles centre val de loire un rayonnement
et une crédibilité nationale
il permettrait surtout d'améliorer les
compétences et la compétitivité de la
3ème région viticole française